gun sales are booming with the FBI
running nearly 200 000 background checks
for Black Friday and the number of
handgun owners carrying daily in the
United States has doubled in four years
what Senator Chris Murphy talking about
here nothing let me tell you what's
wrong with Senator Chris Murphy here
what he says that he wants a defund
police departments that aren't making
arrests on Gunner gun crimes first of
all how do you decide whether or not the
police should make an arrest is it
whether or not there is sufficient
evidence who decides whether there's
sufficient evidence what if the
prosecutor says there isn't sufficient
evidence what if there isn't a
conviction what if the case isn't
cleared they haven't investigated let's
go to the prosecutors what if the
prosecutors like Alvin Bragg decide
we're not even going to prosecute an
arrest so don't even bother to make an
arrest for a gun crime and you want to
talk about Sanctuary let's talk about
Sanctuary cities where illegals who end
up committing crimes are protected from
law enforcement and they're not
prosecuted for crimes you wanted to fund
law enforcement how about you to fund
the FBI they knew about Nicholas Cruz in
the Parkland shooting they knew about
the tsarnae of Brothers they were warned
by Russia twice and while you're at it
what about the fact that in all of these
jurisdictions gun crimes may not be the
priority that murders are for example
and you've defunded everybody already so
they don't have half of the resources
they need for these crimes and let me
tell you one more thing he's basing this
whole thing on the 2021 situation where
the LGBT uh two one Whatever shooter uh
had a problem with his mother he says
and had they done a red flag on this kid
this uh this shooting at the lgbtq club
would have happened you're wrong and
I'll tell you why it was more than a
year ago and that means it would have
expired
wow Chris Murphy just got hit in the
face
what do you have to say about that that
makes a lot of sense can't argue with it
well then I guess I have nothing to say
is that way what you're looking for
so the judge is obviously right about
the expiration on the report of the bomb
threat to his mother but it turns out as
well that in 2015 he had an incident
when he went to live with his
grandparents in San Antonio there was
some online bullying
um and he had lashed out and that was
something that could have been reported
but it wasn't and what Chris Murphy is
talking about is that if there are
communities and this was the first
County after Jared Polis signed the red
flag law in 2019 to say we don't want to
be a part of this that if you don't want
to be a part of it that you shouldn't
get the same level of funding as people
who want to enforce the laws that are on
the books and now in the wake of the
Uvalde shooter shooting if you see how
many Republicans are for red flag laws
this should be updated I don't know if
these policies should exist and maybe we
should have a longer terms on these red
flag law reportings it should be longer
than a year should Alvin Bragg's office
be defunded because these were come
right out and said I'm not going to
prosecute this this this
Sanctuary cities run by democrats
whether it's the governor or local
person so we're not going to arrest on
this this this and this crime let's just
do it across the board
sure well said Judge Jeanine you are on
fire right now
Dana just besides the obvious
lack of common sense that this makes
what about politically you have a
Democrat Senator just stepping in the
defund goo all over so if you want to
make your gun control policies popular
or be persuasive with them you shouldn't
tie them to the defund the police
movement that's what all the Democrats
were talking about as they were facing
tougher races than they wanted to in in
the midterm but that's going back all
four years ago remember that defund the
police was a big problem for them in
2020 as well as when Republicans picked
up seats and also we the the Congress
just passed gun control legislation
this past summer
and it didn't stop the shootings now it
might help prevent some in the future
which would be good but if you want to
have more laws you have to be honest
about the fact that you just passed one
that didn't work why would this be
different and you cannot tie to defund
the police or else you're going to end
up one even more unpopular but two what
you said Jesse that people are buying
guns but those people are buying them
legally and that a lot of these some of
these shooters are buying them legally
so where where's that can I think you
could find consensus bipartisan
consensus that says okay those types of
people should not get guns how do you do
that and I'm not I'm not an expert in
that but I think that's where the you
could pinpoint the problem and people
are asking Santa Claus for weapons this
Christmas wow
hmm
that's an interesting way to get a gun
anyway uh the police yeah
I was enforcing laws until the Dems
decided to stop punishing the violators
that's the problem I think he was trying
to do what the you know the Liberals to
steal from the left they were trying to
own the cons by adopting the sanctuary
language to guns because he thought that
would be clever but the analogy is lousy
because there is no Sanctuary for
breaking gun laws the way there is
sanctuary for breaking immigration laws
uh so it's like the so that's why it's
so confusing because it sounded like he
was saying I'm going to defund the
police even if the police are doing
their job and you legally own a gun
that's what it sounds like but having
said that I love the idea of a sanctuary
City for guns or just a sanctuary
neighborhood because what a great
experiment to take eight blocks of
Manhattan everybody there can legally
own and carry as long as they're
law-abiding citizens they're not
criminals what a great experiment that
would be to see what would happen in
those eight square blocks compared to
the rest of the city everybody would
want to live there to everybody but the
thing is I never do the experiment
because they'll know no one wants to
know the outcome it's like you know when
the movies and the mob movies nobody
commits a crime in a mob neighborhood
yeah yeah it's also but they'll do
experiments of legalizing
um like opium dens yes in the middle of
San Francisco